uh my name is Tim Taylor I operate
Crossroad Farm in post Mills Vermont and
I farm approximately 50 acres of mixed
vegetables we have um Greenhouse
Tomatoes we grow approximately 15 16,000
pounds of those uh uh quite a big
bedding plant business now and in the
field crops Out Here We Grow just a uh
about everything uh one time we even
tried artichokes one year uh we have um
as far as weed strategies uh I think
probably the one I focus on the most is
to keep my corn crop the cleanest I can
I use that as a way to come into my next
Fields because it in my operation it
takes up a great deal of the uh acreage
I like to let no weeds go to seed there
so we'll actually but we use no
herbicide there I want to stress that
right from the start we never have I've
always cultivated it uh I use a single
row cultiv Ator I use a a two row
cultivator the rolling Liston type
cultivators and I use some blind
cultivation with rotary
hose this is a rotary
hoe which we use in uh corn comes in all
different lengths this is actually a
very small one it's been cut down so it
does two rows of
corn we use it for blind
cultivation uh after we've sewed the
corn approximately anywhere from 4 to 5
to oh perhaps a week to 10 days later
depending upon the soil temperature and
the time of the year we'll come in and
we just run this right across the top of
the crop blindly uh this is usually
pre-emergent or just as it's spiking up
I use this in corn I've used it in peas
and in
beans uh it will get about approximately
50 to 60 % of the
weeds uh it will get approximately oh
maybe 2 to 3% of the corn or the crop
you're trying to actually
grow uh depending upon that your
timing uh you can actually come in when
the crop is uh not so much corn but peas
and beans when the crop is actually up
and starting to Leaf
out uh it's one of the pros and the cons
of of this it allows you a little more
time for more finer cultivation because
it does reduce the uh pressure the weed
pressure for a period of time and yet it
doesn't get them all and you still need
to do cultivation I find I still need to
do uh single row cultivation as well uh
each sprocket here is spring-loaded
it'll bear the full weight of the
unit uh you can get a little nervous
sometimes when you use it because it
does sink into the ground quite a ways I
find that I'm quite safe as long as I
keep my corn planted at 2in level corn
planted up a little in the 1-in zone
will tend to be dug up a little more
often and one of the problems with this
tool is that it picks up all my loose
plastic from
my crops like melons and zucchini and
squash I don't know if it's exactly a
downsize it gets it out of the
field which I do want to get it out
the other primary cultivation tool I use
is a slightly modern version of 2in
shovels we call these the
curbco bat
wings and they're for single row
cultivation although I have seen them
used in in other applications in two and
three and four
cultivation what they consist of is a
series of old car bumpers that have been
fashioned into these bat wings for
throwing dirt uh some of the things I I
really like about it are if I have some
very mature weeds and then come in quite
late uh it will it cuts under them and
cuts them quite effectively and rips
them up uh it's quite effective where I
do have some witch grass CU again it
rips it
up
well here we have the budding basket
weeder and what we do here is we plant
all our lettuce is grown from and is
transplanted we do do nothing from seed
into the field it's all transplanted and
it's a two row bed
system and a week after transplanting
approximately we'll come in with a
budding basket here which is ground
driven off of this chain here and we we
can go approximately oh just about as
fast as you'd want to drive it on the
open field uh 5 mil an hour or so uh it
doesn't its Advantage is that it won't
throw dirt into the lettuce it'll just
it moves in this manner and kicks up the
weed seeds cultivating at about 1 in
depending upon where I set it in the
ground
wait about a week because we get a
little bit of germination but we don't
want to wait too long because we don't
want the weeds to be too big the
advantage of the belly Mount is that it
does not wander the cul the cultivating
tool doesn't wander in the field as it
would behind the tractor if it was
placed behind the tractor I'm able to
view straight down at the at the uh
single row I can't see both rows but I
can see one row and I just uh can see
exactly where I'm placing the tool tool
absolutely exactly if I daydream a
little bit and it wanders off I can
catch it real quick whereas when it's
behind me in the case of some of the
three-point hitch tools that I use for
cultivation it it tends to wander a
little more and I tend not to have quite
the same control that I would have
wanted to stress this I own two of these
cotas and this is mounted here all year
long I don't take this off it's not
difficult to mount it's just has four
bolts here and four bolts on the other
side but I have set just perfectly the
way I want it and I honestly believe you
should have a tractor for each piece of
cultivating equipment you have uh
because the downside on all cultivation
is the setup
time what we do is the the basket is
spaced 6 Ines apart and I'll do two
passes here the first pass I'll be
nursed right up next to the radishes
down one side I'll turn around and come
back in the same bed up against the
other side as close as I can go in that
that way I get within usually an inch to
2 in of the
crop even though I have 6in spacing on
the
basket here's the profecta field
cultivator this is something new for me
that I'm just experimenting this year
with I hope it's going to be uh reduce
my Reliance upon a
rator uh in my field bed preparation
normally what are my present practice is
to
uh subsoil in the spring put the subsoil
on a two shank subsoiler run around the
entire 30 40 Acre Farm
subsoiling and then gradually manure and
rivate and make beds as I need them
uh and then in the fall once again use
the rator to incorporate the residue
and I have some concerns about soil
structure and I'm trying to uh look for
alternatives to that uh and especially
the bed preparation in the spring and
also in again in for witch grass
control